She has one of the earliest serial
killers in recorded history.
The original sadomasochistic femme fatale.
She stands out as a shocking
lesson in just down dangerous.
The sadistic,
demented,
powerful women can be the passing
of the centuries has left us with an
incomplete picture of the
true nature of our crimes,
but what we do know is truly stomach
Channing and this week's biographics.
We pair into the depraved
life of the blood count tests.
Elizabeth battery.
Okay.
The women we know is Elizabeth Bathory.
It was born as early a bit Bathory on
August the seventh 1560 in nearby store in
the Kingdom of Hungary.
She was born into one of the most
prominent families in central Europe.
As a result,
she was lavished with the very best
education in classical upbringing.
During our formative years,
she learned to speak Hungarian,
Slovak,
Greek,
Latin,
and German.
Elizabeth was a child with
severe health problems.
Historians have speculated that the fact
that her parents were first cousins may
have contributed to how weak constitution
she was an epileptic and as such was
prone to violence,
seizures.
It has been recorded that young Elizabeth
was exposed to all sorts of horrific
atrocities during her formative years.
She has said to have begun laughing
at the site of a man who's crime was
stealing being soon into
the body of a horse.
She would also regularly witness the
severe beatings of servants unlike other
young girls.
So Elizabeth was not offended
by the violence that she saw.
In fact,
she seemed to be drawn to it.
By the age of 10 she had become a
rather stunningly beautiful young lady.
It was then that she became engaged to
a 15 year old Hungarian counts by the
name of fairing can Nadasky
as was the custom sheet,
moved into our future husbands,
parents palace and received education.
Then running the estates that were under
the control of her mother and yeah,
Legend has it that Elizabeth had
an affair with a hasn't bought,
you know,
early teens and became pregnant.
It is said that she gave
the child away secretly.
Meanwhile,
Aaron's is supposed to
have discovered the affair,
had the peasants castrated and
then thrown to a pack of wild dogs.
Whether this story is true or not,
it is clear that Elizabeth
was active sexually.
She married Ferenc on May the eighth
1574 when she was 14 the wedding,
it was an extravagance of fair with
four and a half thousand people in
attendance.
The party raged on for three days at the
height of which parents gifted his wife
with a castle of her own.
It just so happens to be
causal trash tits out,
one of the darkest,
most bleakly gothic
castle in all of Hungary.
The car situations in the literal
Carpathians and modern day Slovakia.
We're surrounded by a
village and farmland.
It would come to be the scene of
many of our most horrific crimes,
the marriage at United
to powerful families,
and it made them the
power couple of the day.
For the first few years,
Elizabeth was busy learning about and
overseeing the many estates that she
controls.
Her husband was off fighting
against the Ottomans.
He proved to be a great warrior,
noting himself.
The nickname of the black
knight of Hungary is absolute
brutality in the face of
the enemy.
Terrified his enemies
since shocked his allies.
The Turks invaded Hungary in 1591
precipitating what had become known as the
long war,
which lasted from 1593 to 1606 the wall
was to drag on severely depleting the
Hungarian economy.
However,
Elizabeth Bathory never felt the pinch
because a husband kept showering her with
gifts from the Ottoman Empire.
In fact,
a couple of groups so wealthy that during
this time they actually lends money,
do the Hungarian Habsburg Empire
to keep the country a flute.
During the war years cashed it
set was threatened by the tax.
Elizabeth had to defend her husband's
estate since she did so effectively at
times.
Street also gave refuge to desperate
peasants feeding and housing them.
Over the first few
years of their marriage.
Elizabeth and foreigns didn't
spend much time together.
When they did it said they bonded
over their love of violence.
Torturing young servant girls
see were under their charge.
Ferentz taught his teenage wife innovative
methods of torture such as rolling up
pieces of oils,
paper,
placing it in between the toes of a
seven girl and then setting it on fire.
It was also claims that he gave Elizabeth
the Claude Glove for her to scratch up
the faces of disobedient girls.
There is no doubt that a husband
introduced Elizabeth Duke or manner of
atrocity,
but there was another evil influence
in 1601 the household was joined by a
strange woman by the
name of Anna Doll Volya.
It was rumored that she was a witch.
What is undeniable though,
is that Elizabeth's personality underwear.
It's a dramatic change
from the time the Darboy.
Yeah,
and to the household.
She became much more sadistic,
whereas the husband taught her to
torture Anna towards her to kill.
Under the sinister to Jovana,
Elizabeth was responsible for the
deaths of several of her servants.
Around this time,
the disappearances of the girls raised
new eyebrows as peasants were completely
disposable at that time and place.
Any questions that were raised by
family members were squelched quickly by
virtue of the huge power that the
battery family hat Elizabeth was in all
practical tans untouchable.
She could torture and kill
to our heart's delight.
Even the power of the family though
could not prevent the reamers.
Local pastors became
increasingly suspicious.
There's Elizabeth more frequently asked
them to come to the castle to perform a
funeral rites for serving girls
who had apparently died of cholera.
It is recorded that one priest,
after having attended too many funerals,
pulled her aside and said to her,
your grace should not have acted so
because it offends the Lord and we will be
punished if we do not complain
to you and criticize your grace,
and in order to find my words aren't true,
we need only exume the body and you will
find that the marks identify the way in
which death occurred.
Elizabeth was outraged
that the priest would deck.
He was there in this Nana.
She threatens that she
had powerful relatives.
He would not tolerate such talk.
She then stormed out of the charge,
leaving it for her husband to smooth
things over with the priest together.
The murderous couple had five known
children with the youngest being born in
1598 around 60 no one Elizabeth's
husband ferrets became unwell.
We don't know the specific
nature of his condition,
but it led to paralysis.
If the legs,
he died in 1604 bringing their 29 year
marriage to an ends at the time of her
husband's death.
Elisabeth was 44 years of age.
The loss of her husband cost
another noticeable change,
and Elizabeth Sevens notice that
she became even more sadistic.
The stress of having to take the reigns
of an extensive Ambar was no doubt a
contributing factor.
It appears that she now transformed our
pension for sadism from a hobby into a
full time preoccupation,
specifically Eby torture and murder of
young women with almost 407 girls savor
the banks with our vast remains.
Elizabeth had no shortage of victims,
of course,
killing our staff.
It was a bit of a hassle as him
and that she had to replace them.
So she increasingly began to lure
girls from the villages surrounding our
castles.
When she had had her fill of
torturing these unfortunates,
they would be flying over the castle
walls to be ripped to pieces by wolves.
Elizabeth built up a loyal team of
sycophancy facilitated have murderous
actions.
I know Delvoye.
Yeah.
Was her main accomplice also
brought into these statistics cycle?
Was the nurse who looked
after the children,
a woman by the name of a year and a Joe.
There was also a friend of hers
involved by the name of [inaudible].
There was also a washer
woman by the name of Katelyn,
the most sinister of the helpers,
Anna and darker,
who would try to outdo each other
and inflicting pain on their victims.
The youngest of the murderous clan was
a disfigured team by the name of fit
Skyrim.
The typical progression of a seven girl
into this horror would begin with a
simple mistake and the
performance of her duties.
This could be as menial
as missing a stitch,
the counts as if she was
present with fixing evil,
stare on the girl,
yell at her,
and then begin snapping her arounds.
Elizabeth,
the device,
all manner of creative punishments to
go with specific misdemeanors and eagles
who made a mistake in any kind of sewing
would be stabbed repeatedly with it.
Long sewing needles.
Usually girls would be stripped
naked before they were tortured.
Elizabeth reveled in inflicting
psychological torture on the victims after
sticking to needles into
the fingers of a girl.
She would comment,
if it hurts the whore,
she can pull it out.
The girl would naturally take,
this is permission to pull the needle out.
But when she did,
Elizabeth would pull out a
knife and cut the finger off.
She was also known to have at least one
occasion bitten a chunk of flesh from
the face of one of her victims.
Services would be lucky to get
away with a lost finger or two.
More often than not,
the blood lust within the deprived
heart of the Countess was unable to be
quelled.
The girls would be dragged
off to a torture chamber
where Elizabeth employee to
torture squad to carry out
much of her daddy work.
All manner of implements were made you
soft cause the most gruesome afflictions
imaginable.
Pins says we used to rip flesh insides
were torn out and there there've even
been reports that cannibalism was
enforced on some of the girls.
We know certain details of what took
place in the torture chambers of the
battery castles because of investigation
and trial transcripts that occurred
when face eventually caught up with
Elizabeth Bathory in our accomplices.
However,
over the centuries the legends took over
and many of the crimes attributed to
her.
Oh yeah.
Fiction.
Perhaps the most pervasive belief is that
she had blood drained from virgins and
would bathe in us in order to
preserve her youthful beauty.
This story is almost certainly,
I'm sure you've not one of these seven
girls who've testified against bathroom.
He mentioned anything to do with the
practice rather accounts after accounts
mentions that the floors of the
torture chambers were covered in blood,
which they would then have to clean up.
The counters showed absolutely no interest
in preserving the blood as part of
some narcissistic beauty regime by 1609
the rumors of what we're taking place at
the battery castles were rife,
but there was nothing the law
could do to put a stop to it.
At that time,
peasants were unable to
bring charges against nobles.
Some parents even looked at the demented
counters as a source of ready revenue
selling their children to have
for a lump sum on the face of it,
the trade was made to
provide seven duties,
but if the child was to die of cholera,
what of it Elizabeth?
Appetite for blood was insatiable.
The bodies were piling up at such a rate
that how group of enablers web running
out of places to bury them.
Many of the girls were placed in shallow
graves and the costs or courtyards,
and some of them were dug up by hungry
dogs by the beginning of 1,609 and this
is what's closest confidant and adopt.
Valia died of a stroke
around this same time,
Huh?
Debts began to mounts with all of
the children grown and married.
The counters fell into a spiral
of loneliness and depression.
For some reason,
Elizabeth decided that she needed
to find a better class of victim.
We don't really know why,
but the general belief is that a lady
steward as the major rover who many
believe to be or which convinced her
that if she took the lives of noble girls
how financial fortunes with turn arounds
or it may simply have been that she was
running out of peasant victims.
Whatever the reason for the change it led
to Elizabeth to the decision to open a
finishing school for young women.
It would be the perfect cover for her
to continue her torture us ways with a
higher class of victim.
At the same time,
the attendance fees that the parents of
the girls paid would infuse some much
needed funds into the battery coffers.
Bye Now as appeared that Elizabeth is
insatiable need to kill the young girls
and led to the depths of insanity.
It's certainly clouded our reasoning.
It was obvious that the aristocratic
parents of teenage girls who suddenly
disappeared would move heaven and
earth to get to the bottom of what had
happened to their pride and joy,
but none of that mattered to Elizabeth.
All she saw was a ready
supply of nubile young bodies.
Inevitably the body counts began
adding up and the parents came calling
Elizabeth May dumped the
bizarrest of excuses.
One of the girls had gone crazy and
killed the other girls before committing
suicide,
but no one was convinced.
Some parents appeal to the King Mathius
the second and he decided to undertake
an investigation.
The official Raul investigation was put
into the hands of the king's highest
ranking representative [inaudible].
This man happened to be one of Elizabeth's
dead husband's closest associates on
his deathbed friends that even
asked us to look out for his wife.
However,
there's his loyalty to the king was
stronger than that of his old friend.
Still,
he treated Elizabeth with a level of
respect that she would not have otherwise
have received that.
As I began to interview witnesses,
he soon had dozens of people
that you testified to.
The counters is depraved ways.
Seven zoo,
it managed to get out of
the cost of their lives.
Spoke of seeing blood drenched wools,
hearing terrible screams and noticing the
ever growing readymade cemetery in the
castle courtyard.
However,
none of the people that Thursday spoke
to you was an actual eye witness of the
torture.
Thursday you became convinced
of Elizabeth skills.
However,
he felt terrible about the pledge that
he had made to his dying friends that he
would account for his widow.
He decided to write,
do Elizabeth's relatives
and ask for advice.
A secret agreement was reached by which
the as it would be able to complete his
investigation,
but Elizabeth would never
be brought to trial.
She would go direct need to prison without
the embarrassment and the family that
a public trial would bring.
It's interesting to note
that none of batteries,
relatives argued that she was
innocent by December of 16,
10,
Thursday,
believed that he had enough
evidence to arrest Elizabeth,
but he wanted to make absolutely sure.
Therefore,
he had himself in the king,
invited to dine at Battery Castle and
Elizabeth was forensically nervous,
but she tried to act.
The gracious hostess things went
well until she saved the men.
Uh,
post dinner dessert,
a cake on first divide.
The men began to feel unwell,
convinced that the contest
had tried to poison them.
They may just be the accent.
On New Year's Eve,
16,
10,
Thursday returned with a
contingent of armed guards.
They had outside the castle gates and
wait it before a long Elizabeth and our
lady Stewart as the major river
came out to Costa Protective,
spelled designed to protect the
countess and bringing about the death of
investigator.
Thursday.
Thursday one is men listens
to the women's incantations.
When the two went inside,
the investigators crept
towards the is entranceway.
They immediately noticed the mutilated
body of a young girl and near the doorway
to more were found just inside.
They then heard the sounds of screaming,
which led them to the torture chamber.
It was there that they discovered
Elizabeth's murder team harder at work.
It is unclear whether the Thursday
actually caught Elizabeth in the act of
torture.
However,
he was now convinced if that guilt,
the contest was found
and taken into custody.
She immediately claimed their innocence,
blaming everything on her servants.
Those,
uh,
wasn't moved.
However,
and see through Elizabeth
into her own dungeon.
In the end,
306 people testified against Elizabeth.
Even the members of her murder grew
turned against a incriminating themselves.
In the process.
The total reported murder counts
varies between 80 and 650 batteries.
Accomplices were put on trial in January
of 1611 scores of witnesses and even
some surviving victims
took to the witness stands.
The judges is also examined some of the
cadavers that had been taken from the
battery consuls death
sentences were passed down to
I own a Joe Dorko and Fisco.
Prior to their executions I own a Jo
Anne Dorko were given that own form of
torture.
Their fingers were torn out by iron tongs
before they were put to death and then
tossed on a bonfire.
FISCO was spared this
torture due to his youth.
Instead it was beheaded and then burns.
Catelynn was the only one
who was not put to death.
She had been the most softhearted
of the bunch on several occasions.
She herself had been beaten for
sneaking food in for the victims.
She was sentenced to life imprisonment.
That was,
I kept his word to Elizabeth
and she was never put on trial.
She was convicted and sentenced to
life imprisonment in our own castle.
A confined to one of the dungeons
which had been the scene of some of her
atrocities are only visitors,
were priests and the man
who had put him behind boss.
That was like the Kyries reported that
she was unrepentant and crazed with rage.
None of the priests was able to get it
to acknowledge the severity of our crimes
and she continued to insist
that it was a assistance.
Who are the real criminals are priests
challenge tower as to why she didn't
order them to stop.
She said that she had been afraid of them.
Elizabeth reserve the greatest
animosity for Thursday.
At one point when he came to see her,
she began to subjects him to an awful
harangue at which points and to Jack did.
You are in the last months of your life.
You do not deserve to breathe the air on
the earth or see the light of the Lord.
You shall disappear from this world and
never really it again as the shadows and
develop you.
May you find time to repent,
you'll be steal life.
Elizabeth Bathory complained to a guard
that she had cold hands on October the
21st 1614 he told us to go lie
down and tried to get some sleep.
She did,
and she never woke up.
Her body was buried in the
cemetery at [inaudible],
but it said that it didn't remain there
long due to local uproar at the outrage
of having such a murderous
buried in their midst.
The body was supposedly exhumed
and taken to the battery family,
Krebs.
However,
when the crypt was opened in 1995
the corpse of Hungary's most infamous
murderous was nowhere to be seen.
So I'm not going to ask
if he enjoyed the video,
but I do hope you found it interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below
and don't forget to subscribe brand new
videos just like this
every day of the week.
And as always,
thank you for watching.